اراد محمد قبل الرجوعه الى جامعته خارج
البلاد ان يزور القدس ويصلي في المسجد
الاقصى لكنه لم يعد من هناك فقد قتلته
شرطه الاحتلال الله يرحمه
[موسيقى]
دكتور
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل في بلدته حوره في النقب استبدلت
تجهيزات الاحتفاء بتخرجه بخيمه عزاء فمحمد
كان في اجازه قصيره قبيل اجراء امتحانه
الاخير في مجال الطب وحدادا على استشهاده
اعلنت قياده المجتمع الفلسطيني داخل الخط
الاخضر الاضراب العام ورفضت روايه
الاحتلال ان محمد حاول خطف سلاح من عناصر
الشرطه قرب باب السلسله في المسجد الاقصى
روايه تبناها مسؤولون اسرائيليون بل
واقترح وزير الامن القومي منح وسام شرف
لمن اطلق النار على الطبيب الفلسطيني
واثنان تنياه على ما قامت به الشرطه
نحن نتحرك ونقاتل المخربين وقد قضت قواتنا
في الاشهر الاخيره على عشرات منهم واعتقلت
المئات امنح الدعم الكامل للشرطه
الاسرائيليه على تصفيتها مخربا في جبل
الهيكل نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
وجودي منظومه كاميرات مراقبه لشرطه
الاحتلال في المسجد الاقصى ومحيطه فان
الشرطه لم تنشر اي توثيق لما حدث بخلاف
مرات اخرى كانت تسارع فيها لنشر اثبات
لروايتها وهو ربما ما لا تملكه هذه المره
ويبقى التوثيق الوحيد في هذه المرحله صوت
رصاصه بل عده رصاصات قتلت محمد
في مكان يقصده الناس للصلاه وابتغاء
السكينه
نجوان سمري الجزيره من بلده حوره صحراء
النقب